Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
When your business needs a logo,
website,
business card,
thumbnail,
or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for banner ads,
illustrations,
and much more.
With 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs from designers around the world.
Give your feedback and then pick your favorite.
Your happiness is guaranteed to check out some of my competitions in designs and
some of your competitions and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim and right now you can get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
this episode is brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I've interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports,
and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder Andy Puddicombe,
a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is p,
if you want to look that up,
but otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash Tim.
Hello Ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
my dog is yawning and it is my job to deconstruct world class performers of
various types from military to entertainment to academia to sports chess,
everything in between and tease out the routines,
habits,
favorite books,
etc that you can use.
And this episode we have Luis von Ahn on Louis phone on von a h n who is an
entrepreneur and computer science professor at Carnegie Mellon University.
He is known for inventing captures and we'll get into that.
Being a MacArthur fellow,
which is often nickname the genius grant and selling two companies to Google in
his twenties Luis has been named one of the 10 most brilliant scientists by
popular science magazine,
one of the 50 best brains in science by discover,
one of the top young innovators under 35 by the MIT technology review and one of
the 100 most innovative people in business by Fast Company magazine.
He has many things,
many interests that to keep him busy,
but the primary is Duolingo.
Luis is currently the cofounder and CEO of Duolingo,
a language learning platform created to bring free language learning to the
world.
They have more than 100 million users,
including yours truly,
and that makes it the most popular way to learn languages in the world than it
is the most downloaded app in the education category on both iTunes where it has
a five star average and more than 3,300 reviews and Google play.
I first met Luis as an early investor in Duolingo.
I tracked them down,
which was very hard.
I tracked Louise and his cofounder Severin down after you guys.
My fans actually told me I had to see it.
It was in Beta at the time and via Twitter and Facebook you guys informed me.
I reached out to them.
That's how that came together.
And every time I meet Louis I learned something new and certainly I hope you
will learn a lot.
In this episode we talk about his favorite books and resources you'd recommend
to entrepreneurs,
language learning tips,
the very clever way he caught cheating students at Carnegie Mellon,
which is a great story.
Early mentors and key lessons learned,
the story of building and selling companies like recapture how to recruit and
vet technical talent.
Uh,
the most surprising sources of users for Duolingo.
And it goes on and on.
So we talk about quite a lot.
Please say hello to Luis on Twitter at Lewis Fon,
n l U.
Say hi on the interwebs and please enjoy my conversation with Luis Luis.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks for having me,
Tim.
And I thought we could start where a lot of people start in the morning,
which is breakfast.
You mentioned this briefly when we were doing a sound check.
What did you have for breakfast this morning?
I had a Greek yogurt and you,
you added some contexts.
Is that that you've had the same thing for breakfast for the last year,
possibly two or three years.
It's the identical Greek Yogurt is the [inaudible] Greek yogurt to the one they
have to combine the fruit,
but the spoon never fits in there.
That's the one.
And do you,
do you have meals that you repeat for lunch and dinner?
I mean are you,
do you,
have you standardized your daily routine in other ways besides breakfast?
Not,
not that well,
I have a breakfast is pretty standardized.
My,
my,
my lunch is pretty different.
Everyday we got free lunch,
a,
a Duolingo.
I it just,
I eat that.
Got It.
Does standardize the word makes me think of testing.
And when I think of testing,
I actually got pinged by a former student of yours and the students said,
ask him to explain how he catched he,
how he catched.
Boy,
here we go.
I need to study English here,
Kim.
Or was it you kept yeah,
catch no,
I said this unfortunately,
uh,
caught cheaters in your,
one of your classes at Carnegie Mellon and I was hoping maybe you could explain
how that went.
Yeah,
I did the,
I did quite a bit.
Um,
so I,
I used to teach this class.
I'm on leave,
I'm a professor,
but I'm on leave.
Um,
I used to teach this class called great theoretical ideas in computer science,
which is,
um,
kind of the,
the hardest class most people have ever taken in their lives.
Um,
and it's,
it's basically discreet math and,
and,
and it's pretty hard now.
A lot of people use to cheat.
It's a large class.
It's about 200 kids.
A lot of people used to cheat and in different ways.
On a,
I started becoming,
I started becoming really obsessed with catching people cheating.
I,
it was,
I didn't even do anything bad to them after I caught them cheating.
It was more like a fun game for me.
Right.
Um,
so for example,
one of the things they couldn't do is some of the assignments I said,
it is against the class policy to Google.
Um,
um,
now you can think what you want about that policy.
I don't think it's that great of a policy,
but that's a policy that I inherited.
But that class has always basically said he cannot Google for assignments,
solutions.
Uh,
so one of the things I did was,
um,
I,
uh,
I would,
you know,
sometimes I would assign,
um,
homework and I would actually seed the answers to some of the things in websites
that were crawled by Google,
but that I owned,
uh,
and I could tell people's Ip addresses and everything.
I would catch people cheating that way.
I basically set up honey box for people to cheat and,
and you know,
you could say that's entrapment,
but that's,
that's what I did.
Do you recall any examples off hand?
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
well of the exact websites,
I don't know where they are or the terms.
I mean,
yeah,
one of them was,
um,
there was,
there was one that was called,
ah,
gear on McChrystal's puzzle.
It's,
it's made up,
but I,
I made that word up beforehand.
I made sure there was no,
no such thing on Google.
And I made a website that had the right solution,
but it recorded everybody's Ip address.
And at Cmu you can figure out,
you know,
their dorm from their IP address so I can figure it out,
which,
which person was actually checking.
It turns out that time of the 200 students,
about 40 Google for the answer.
Um,
and that was fun.
Uh,
I used to do all kinds of things like that.
And then the students were pretty,
um,
there were,
there were all usually scared of,
of almost everything being a trick.
Ah,
so I,
I would do that in the first one or two assignments and then afterwards they
would,
they would learn not to,
not to cheat.
So,
so the,
the story,
the progression I've heard is that you would,
uh,
you would bring up slides silently,
did you do this?
Or it was like a screenshot of whatever it is,
the glory [inaudible] problem or whatever circled then a screenshot of the your,
your,
the who is for the domain site or the domain that people would go to with your
name circled since you own it.
Yup.
That's when you could see the whole class.
You could,
you could see their faces change.
It was,
it was pretty fun.
No,
but you didn't have to actually hunt down each identity,
right?
I mean,
did you offer them a choice?
tell me if this is true.
So the,
the,
the story,
the lore is that you,
would you offered them the option of confessing and take a zero for the
homework?
Otherwise they would get reported or head or is it not?
Is it all,
have you,
who have you been talking to?
That was the case that that was exactly the case because it took a little bit of
effort to go and figure out who was who.
Uh,
so I would just,
I would say if you,
if you just confess you got a zero on the assignment on and all kinds of people
confess.
I even had some people confess it didn't even actually do anything.
They just say,
well,
you know,
I don't know what the hell I was doing,
so I'm just going to throw my name in there.
I'd rather take a zero on the assignment
if we rewind the clock.
So that's as a professor,
when did you become,
at what age did you become a professor at Carnegie Mellon?
Um,
it was probably 25.
25.
Yeah.
And was it clear that you are going to be involved with computer science from a
very young age?
Could you describe for people where you grew up a little bit about your
childhood?
Yeah,
sure.
I grew up in Guatemala,
uh,
which is by the way,
it's,
that's not where they keep the prisoners.
That's Guantanamo.
Do you get that a lot?
I get that a lot.
It's like,
is that way they keep the prisoners that no,
it's not.
Uh,
it's also not where they in Brendan invented the avocado sauce of the Guacamole,
uh,
different.
Um,
so the,
uh,
yeah,
I grew up in Guatemala.
Uh,
I started liking computers at about age eight.
My mom,
I really wanted a Nintendo because everybody wanted to intend though our or my
friends all had an intense dose on.
And I told my mom,
but my mom had gotten me a commodore 64.
[inaudible] 64.
Yeah,
a lot of spy hunter on color.
60 feet.
Yes.
I played a lot of games there.
Uh,
but at first when I first got here,
I was pretty pissed off because I thought,
man,
I want an endo.
Um,
but instead she got me that and she said,
well,
you figure that out.
Uh,
and so I,
uh,
I had to figure out how to use the computer to play games.
Um,
and then I started trying to figure out,
you know,
because you only would buy me a couple of games a year and I would get of them.
I started trying to figure out how to get more and more games and you know,
the best way to do that was basically the copy them from other people.
Uh,
so I started doing that at a young age.
Um,
I don't,
I think the statute of limitations has passed by now,
but I was basically pirating games that an enlarge scale in Guatemala city is
basically what I was doing.
And what did you,
what did you learn in those early days of copying games that,
that helped you later?
Or give you an indication that you had a proclivity for using computers and
computer science?
I was pretty good at,
I mean,
I,
you know,
most of these things had some sort of copy protection.
Uh,
usually it was like hidden files or something that if you just knew how to list
the directory,
uh,
with,
by,
by showing the hidden files,
you could see them.
Uh,
so it was,
it was not that hard.